hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to the evil within now
in the last episode we woke up after
being gurnie through a hospital corridor
and we woke up to a kind of insane
asylum Hospital type setting which again
goes along the outlast route but I'm
very excited to keep finding out more
about this game bodies found in lakeside
town cause of death remains a mystery
more than a dozen mutilated bodies found
in the village of Elk River several
residents unaccounted for what about the
whole city following a part deal was
that not important to you I picked that
up off-camera so I don't know if you
guys were able to read that before did I
just pick up a brain in a jar okay
alright I'm okay with it
anybody there yeah anybody there I
seemed rather calm for being thrust into
such an odd situation unless I'm gonna
assume that they were trying to save my
life hello oh that's nice oh good I was
wondering on the bugs we're gonna start
crawling up the wall when are they gonna
start crawling up a little hi hi lady
are you doing okay don't come near us
alright City you are the only soul here
the only soul here ah what happened to
the bugs on the wall oh why did they get
replaced by this symbol what does it all
mean I'm not gonna follow her right away
I want to see what this is all that just
seems like the end of the corridor
there's weird symbols on the doors I'm
wondering that's markings for whoever's
there anybody there anybody in this
weird mirror or oh come on I was really
hoping for something to happen with that
there's no other reason for me to crawl
all the way over there
I was trying to find the secrets I
really want to be very thorough about
this game because there's a lot here
there's a lot of detail in these games
especially when it comes going on yeah
that's my question but there's a lot of
detail in these triple a horror games
and stuff like that just little nuances
throughout the world but I want to see
for you it seems like a simple question
why can't you answer that I do I really
want to oh okay well alright then thank
you what does that mean is that electric
chair for some sort of examination chair
are you gonna do a procedure on me
there's got to be more stuff around here
that I can explore but I'm not able to
see very much I've got a very close
perspective on this guy's shoulder not
that his broad shoulders aren't very
very interesting to look at I'm kind of
more interested in the environment at
this point but I'll play your game
using those rules what kind of medicine
alcohol based medicine I'm pretty sure
that's what you are hold up well why did
my thing pop up there oh lady lady I
don't think I will
especially in this chair why that symbol
that's a bad symbol lady lady I want to
have a word with you I have been
apparently placing my face right in your
boobs I'm sorry about that that was
inappropriate I'll sit in turnout I'm
sorry here we go thanks lady I'm
horribly injured and I seem to recall
someone with a Bolton
I know it I know it it doesn't seem like
it is stop upgrade why I'm upgrading
myself what happened
maybe okay that's where all the fire
came from is that like is that like the
weird unlock upgrade room where I go to
whenever I fall unconscious it's inside
my own mind I'm guessing I'm the only
soul alive in there in where is going on
uh-huh okay so there's this syringe the
origin of the medication in this travel
syringe is unknown but it provides
moderate moderate health restoration how
would I know that I just picked up a
random syringe in a park I'm gonna jab
it into my arm cuz it makes me feel good
that is so questionable okay press are
down whoa they're all in my brain I need
to use that okay so how do I equip you
kind of hard to do that when I have to
oh I see oh yeah I feel better already
let's just mosey on down this way maybe
I'll get something to actually shoot
because I'm pretty sure there is combat
in this particular game but I'm
wandering through the dark creepy woods
are we going to be borrowing a little
bit of element from cylinder man now
where am I going
what is that oh that looks good well
that looks real good Oh what is that
what is that oh what is that oh it's a
is that a donkey that's a cow I think oh
alright then let's mosey on my way down
somewhere else how am I supposed to know
where I'm supposed to go oh there we go
the bright light in the distance I'm
assuming that would be the one so what
was with all the the city falling apart
and all that jazz why was that a thing
was that real well alright then I'll
just take this lamp I love this land it
makes me look so good gritty and manly
hey totally normal person hello fellow
human I only fell down a frickin cliff
I'll be fine
this is good that guy seems to be
coughing uncontrollably and cly clocking
at his face it's gonna turn out real
well sir sir sir oh no he's bullying
food into his face that's that's good ah
yes this gun I meant to take totally
subtly
Harley Connelly
[Applause]
got a pig in the head there breath my
head shot boom gotcha
wait where to go Oh where does the body
go what the hell where's my lantern how
do I get let me get my lantern what oh
god he's up what the hell I thought he
was dead I shot him in the freaking head
man boom
are you done my god Matt God I shot him
I can't believe I shot him I'm so
concerned for my own sanity
there's my goddamn lamp I didn't see it
before I thought he body disappeared in
any oh well that looks fun why did he
eat him directly on the neck and then go
through the rest of his body they're all
good brain juice my favorite I'll be
able to do all sorts of upgrades with
this put them in strained syringes that
I find and inject them straight into my
arm okay wait oh I get it so the
lanterns permanently just on my hip
that's a good place for it I have one
dude oh no you're the hospital guy it
would be bad to shoot you you're normal
right hello what hurts were you warning
me about this you are Leslie right I'm a
police officer
maybe I should help you maybe [ __ ] how
am I gonna get you to a hospital dude
[ __ ] okay so this is something that
would blow me the hell up okay so I got
to disarm the trap I would just go under
it I would not risk that explosive
literally right by my head for that
let's carry on a little slowly be a
little cautious about this because there
could be something that would blow me up
at anymore
all right Leslie Leslie all right left
bumper sprint okay so I got a stamina
bar kind of reminds me of Red Dead
Redemption for a little bit just a
gun-slinging dude hello crows using
matches rose and fallen enemy and press
B to burn them oh why do I know that
that's not something that I would just
do plus it's not like a body just burns
automatically press B to burn them from
all my cigarette lighting I need to burn
you wait I don't oh I need to pick up
the matches first okay got it
well you son of a [ __ ] you deserve this
I guess okay that's good I'm happy about
this I'm happy that this drunk cliche of
a detective this is burning all the
bodies you see could be alive could be
totally sane burn it anyway just be safe
about this blood-stained or in the shape
of a crow or no that's the shape of the
symbol of the thing like the hospital
symbol
the mere or that's what that was oh I
got it I look into myself what are you
looking at dude what's going on ERI man
stop freaking out you're hardcore
detective I got lots of brain juice
finally got my gold badge detective
Sebastian Castellanos I like the sound
of that
seems a long time coming but they say
I'm one of the fastest ever to rise
through the ranks can't wait to get
started I know that I can do more good
as a detective than I ever could as a
beat cap plus I don't have to wear that
damn uniform anymore the pay bump
doesn't hurt either
Casey PD needs all the help they can get
there's a seemingly disproportionate
amount of crime these days crimson city
is my home and it's my job to protect it
also it just exploded walk towards that
strange broken mirror yeah that's a
pretty cool system like it's a same
system upgrade system and it's part of
the story that's really cool yeah you
must be going a little crazy there no
everyone else is crazy you're not crazy
wait a minute where these doors always
oh everything's in color now that one
makes a difference I knew that mirror
had to be something a bad dream this is
oh I sing nurse inside my brain so
you're gonna do something else there
okay thank you I'm just gonna save and
be on my way
gonna inject more green goop into my
brain and everything's gonna be fun I
want to are the first upgrade even did
it just like upgrade my sanity enough
wake up
or maybe that's a toll I have to pay 200
cool stuff but they need so many points
I don't have nearly enough brains how
can I upgrade my gun with brain juice it
must be that the other world is inside
my mind still it's like Inception I'm
going deeper levels into my own brain ah
I could upgrade reload time accuracy
might be nice get more headshots that
would probably save some things grenades
oh yeah matches I don't know how much I
need those but I'll go for accuracy
because there's the only thing I can buy
right now what that felt fun alright
then so I guess that's it I gotta get
out of here thanks lady
thanks for the green group injection
yeah everything out there not in here
must still be a part of my brain lady
okay bye
you're nice but he's still weird I
imagine that she's like some part of my
past or something oh that's shiny
I'll walk towards this yeah it's gonna
get expensive if I have to keep breaking
mirrors everytime I go into my brain I
need actually my don't have another
syringe or something oh I can put them
to my hotbar okay so that I can get
there I guess I'm out of syringes I
didn't realize that go well that was a
little all right then you do your thing
I didn't realize that the guy was still
alive so I let him hurt me a little more
and I didn't mean to I guess I just
gotta be careful about this he might
still be alive back there I didn't
exactly burn his bottle
Leslie wait a minute what no no you
leave Leslie alone I've only got one
bullet for this so I'm gonna have to
score this headshot oh oh I like it I
like it
this guy won't see what's coming he
could just be a friend and they're
playing hide and seek you know like
normal people would that groaning
moaning are covered in injuries in blood
I didn't fool around with that all right
I'll burn it don't get up even though I
stab you directly in your brain just
stoke it up Leslie Oh so the door was
unlocked the whole time
Leslie hey I'm coming for you where's
the blacksmith a runaway that's a lot of
spit hey you have a key if you see the
key around here have you seen a robed
man anyone with a hood
that's pretty in the distance is that a
lighthouse or is that a church was that
a hospital is that mount massive asylum
from outlast good lordy Lou there's a
there's a black man in LA where is it
okay am I supposed to distract someone
here is it gonna be big guy oh no it's
just who the hell is that that Leslie's
grandpa that I'm about to old hey are
you guys from around here
I don't know yeah I just don't trust
anyone man I can't go on
Oh
so that's where this game stalls so
that's where this game's thing about
frickin barbed wire came from whole
games got a hard-on for it apparently so
if I can throw this over yonder way that
means that I would be able to sneak up
behind him and kill him
with a sneak attack whoops
you don't see a thing I said you don't
see a thing
oh god he sees a thing oh I split your
head right open Oh God that didn't do
the trick
by the way how do I melee melee oh I'm
in a panic situation oh no I'm a light
I'm pressing all of that oh there we go
that's how I melee why melees come here
come here breath okay leave me yes oh
we're gonna go do the Smackdown brother
good idea but I'm doing it anyway I'm
almost dead ouch
well oh I just casually fall over them
who's gonna be bad I needed to do the
bottle better the only reason tensional
II died there so that I go back and do
the thing in the bottle so I I need to
do that better so he's not facing me as
soon as I am there come on over
hey dude
fine you know what I'll throw it over
there
that way he'll be inclined to turn
around go for the noise yeah go for it
man yeah what was that
totally weird I know oh well I'm a
little faraway aren't I
I didn't plan this
through I did not think this all god
damn it again with this thing fine I'm
gonna run away I'm gonna hide he's never
gonna know I'm here there's no point in
hiding now I'll take that I'll take the
green goop oh just be on my way then
oh hey how's it going bro oh wait a
minute
yes gotcha [ __ ] what's up burn your
body who's hamro oh whoops well then
looks like you came to the right place
we've got a party going on here you'll
never know what game that I don't
completely suck at I kind of suck but at
least I don't completely suck that's
what's important when did they put a
lighthouse on the lake has it always
been there that circling light passes
over me passes through me I feel like it
takes something away each time I can't
remember what it was though well then
how do you even care
seems like you guys have been living in
this squalor for a while now I don't
know the city only fell apart like a day
ago maybe even a few hours ago I don't
think that was a time jump anyway but
whatever I don't have time to worry
about that all right what was their body
in here I did not notice the body let me
get my life back on so that I can
actually see I know he'll get exactly
what I needed at this juncture give me
that I that's used at all yeah that
feels good I guess I could hide in there
but I don't need to I'm such a badass I
don't need to hide from these losers
that took them both oh whoa whoa whoa
there got my disarmed you I don't know
what I'm gonna use with all the stuff
that I'm getting but I'm gonna disarm
you enough so that I have some okay
I don't want to take those explosives
with me there's no way that they could
be useful whatever okay so this is kind
oh this is a lake I thought this was
like a long cliff or a valley or
something
but this looks creepy can I dive right
in and swim towards the lighthouse would
that be my best bet I come being cold
just looking at it well okay let's stare
at it for a little bit then oh yeah
that's a good stuff
what are you doing oh this is cinematic
as hell oh look at that that's thumbnail
quality right there baby that's
beautiful
okay so anyway let's go that is a thing
like it's odd how the 235 a form factor
of the video makes it a little more
movie like I mean the graphics are great
by itself and the gameplay is pretty
smooth but just having that little edit
feature
I don't know it's something about the
cinematic quality about that being out
here in like LA in the Hollywood area
you know people talk about all the time
ahh 2 3 5 the only way to watch movies
anymore if anybody makes it in a
different way they're a loser okay so
that guy's over there but I don't want
to immediately tussle with him so I'll
turn off my light snake around in the
darkness see if I can go a back way to
him and stab him in the butt and then
stab him in the brain but brain that's
the order of stab he's staring this way
maybe I should have gone the other way
around probably would have been a good
idea
oh I'm not smart enough to know what's
what don't mind me what what's that
nothing Oh hold on that's cool this is
something I'm throw no well guess I'll
just have to do the old man during
around until I can stab him in the butt
hey sir Sir sir
special delivery of the stabbing nature
ha ha shim-sham flim flam baby love of
your demo I could have just dragged him
right into the fire don't you no no no I
need a waste of match bullets
yes thank you very much I don't know how
many shots it's gonna take to kill those
things but I'm gonna save my bullets
when I can because you never know what
I'm gonna face a boss you know for being
a policeman I seem
oddly equipped to be able to deal with
things I don't think standard police
training is coming up behind people and
stabbing them in the brain and make a
lot of assumptions about this stuff but
everything else seems to be centered
around the bay bro oh my goodness
that guy has so many accessories I don't
need to stab him the brain he's already
been stabbed good golly is that a glass
bottle that I could roll around hey dude
keep looking that way for a long time Oh
even better going that way exactly what
I needed
oh thank you but do I need it
hey what was that further over there Wow
okay bye
didn't even need that bottle but thank
you I like the bottle reminds me of the
Last of Us this is like a continuing
series of it thankfully these mats oh I
picked up the torch why do I need the
torch maybe I could burn more bodies or
just burn this house down since I seem
to be a riotous police man with an edge
the desire to kill everyone I see I'm
gonna burn everything burn it all
oh hello sir how are you doing shall I
burn you yeah you look dead enough as it
is I don't even have the option to burn
you I don't even know if I'm out of
matches or something hello do of me I'm
very strong whoa whoa hey you're alive
that ain't good no not oh god oh god oh
god oh god oh god oh god okay so how do
I reload I okay there that button boom
I'm not as good with the controller as I
am with the mouse and keyboard or else
this guy would already be dead
like I went everywhere whoa it's
gruesome as hell totally badass
alright so it's actually oh I forgot I
put it on my hotbar so what I need to do
is I need to put things like this on my
quick access bar so that I can always
have it I don't know if the torch would
because the torch seems like a temporary
thing but I'll just carry with oh my
favorite I don't know what I can talk I
cannot talk for the life of me whoa that
was way too close
oh my goodness I almost walked right in
there good thing I had my torch jeez I
don't know if I have a like a limit on
my lantern y ou need a torch oh maybe
it's a weapon Oh duh
I can fight things back with it oh yeah
bullets was that wait oh I can go into
the bed oh god why would I want to No
thank you I'm fine I'm a man I'm a manly
man so I'm assuming that if I if I use
this I'll be able to burn enemies if
they come charging at me which would be
a good thing I'm just under a lot of
assumptions right now map fragment good
map fragment number two does that mean I
miss map fragment number one I feel like
I might have missed something I don't
think I've been going through this very
quickly but I haven't been checking all
of the nooks and crannies so I apologize
in advance if I have missed something
I'm not trying to I'm just trying to get
through this as best I can
please please be merciful to me in your
hasty judgments please understand I am
an idiot I'm an idiot looking for a
blacksmith
anything anything intervene now I don't
see anything unless there was something
up here because maybe I was supposed to
come this way first Oh bottle I'll take
that always good to have a ball oh no I
dropped my torch whoa hey whoa oh
there's a dude there Wow let's see how
this works
oh wait no maybe man maybe ever
hey dude hey dude hey dude what was that
uh what's that over there
oh is that a sound of a tasty beverage
go for it man are you doing what are you
what are you doing it wasn't even close
you [ __ ] you looking out the window no
you're looking at a wall you big goof
your big old trap oh that was
uncomfortably close to that trap I still
don't know what I need to do with these
trap things
can I just armed that please got it oh
the creepy good Oh Oh gross oh wait what
is that
look guys right outside hello you Oh
what oh ho bear trap see that seems oh
no oh no whoa whoa wait whoa hey whoa oh
no not again
Oh No how do I I can i I can't what I
can't stab him where's my knife I can't
I use my damn knife my torch a scuse me
I need this
how do you like fire [ __ ]
oh no oh so the torch was the one use
thing oh well fine now it's cool anyway
guys fun I'm actually having a lot of
fun at this I mean I can't say I can't
say that I'm an expert in what I'm doing
right now I probably should be doing
this a little more stealthily dispatched
a few expeditiously with my skill and
women forever forever that was a word
wasn't it okay everyone so I haven't
found anything else and there might have
been a rumor that I didn't check over
here yeah yeah over here is here another
dude another offering plate of some sort
that I need to reach a saving point it's
almost time then this episode here Oh
more health yes please what is that that
is nothing that is a whole lot of
nothing a lot of nothing yeah you know
you think I would have noticed how all
the decrepitude of this location you
know being a police officer I would have
been called to an area like this a long
time ago
so why is all of this new I mean are do
you know the answer to that's because
everything's friggin horrible
thank you yes okay can I take that oh I
can't have those Oh find that that would
have been extremely useful except that I
can't really kill them that quickly
after they do get in the trap hello sir
Oh No look over there well that's a
thing
all right fine then you want to get
blasted in the face I have just the
thing
pakhi oh oh come on head head No
Edie I am the worst i underst I am
literally the worst oh god I'm so bad
there we go finally I'm not good with
the gun I it's this controller cuz I'm
using an actual gamepad I'm not used to
that I haven't played like shooters with
a gamepad since I don't know I played
through Red Dead Redemption and even
that I was bad the only three said I was
good because it was a slow motion
version and like way back when like
freshman year when I was roommates with
Bob
I played halo we played halo a lot in
the Xbox it was just like then I got
good at it because I had a lot of
practice but I'm so far beyond out of
practice with the gamepad but please do
not judge me for how terrible I shoot
that again you already judge me for our
terrible issue with the monster shooter
I am good at games I swear I promise hmm
oh hi oh I should have where'd you come
from
Oh God
I thought I thought it was a race oh
okay well this is this is bad what do i
do what do I do
I should have burned them I am the worst
at sprinting what do I do let me do I
don't know how to fight you when I can't
do that
turn this off sprint around I didn't see
a thing they have no idea where I went I
am a stealthy son of a [ __ ] Oh No I
like how they point right before they
come after me hmm then they'll stumble
so I should be able to go back in sneak
around him oh that guy's dead
I guess so dead oh he's so dead come
here you come here friend come here
friend hey friend you smelling for
something how about you smell nothing
every good and then I burn your body oh
thank you for the bullets Oh where's
that guy now come here are you I'm glad
it's actually kind of easy to get away
from these people then again I think the
barbed wire clouds their judgment a
little bit hey friend don't mind that
bottle that I was kicking around hey you
look good
let me get a good look I'm never gonna
get tired of it let's do fun okay
now I don't have to do this in a blind
panic and scream my head off at nothing
okay yeah okay now that I have bullets
let me reload so just in case I ever
could actually hit someone in the face I
do
[Applause]
that was a good thing I could possibly
I'm sorry
I apologize for making everyone's ears
bleed
alright so back in the woods Oh what
that that looks slightly ominous like I
live over there no he looks kind of dead
is that that dude from amnesia not that
guy but him God oh hello
so I surprised makeup on hands right
just keep doing what you're doing yeah
yeah totally just keep doing that thing
oh well you didn't have to get up come
on what'd I do
oh I thought I'd turn my lantern off
well this is a bat oh there's a lot of
you run run you douche I said I said run
Oh God Dodge Duke okay we're fine we're
fine we're fine
oh my god we're totally fine there's a
lot of dead bodies here I could try to
dispatch them all one by one but that
might take a lot of time
are they still behind me yes they are
[ __ ] better get out of here you should
have said that like five minutes ago
when I screwed up sanctuary
you're badass hell yeah Oh Ninja Gaiden
this [ __ ] I wish I could do that it's
like the only complaint I would have at
that I wouldn't have been able to nail
that headshot even point-blank range oh
and shot myself in the groin yes chapter
2 clear save that [ __ ] oh god this game
is so fun I'm actually thoroughly
enjoying myself alright anyway I'm gonna
end this here because of this episode
has been running a while but either way
thank you all so much for watching I am
having like a blast playing this game
and poor that guy whatever his name was
I don't even remember fellow a police
officer man sorry I had to shoot you in
the face multiple times and then burned
your oh it didn't burn your body so
we're okay there but just thank you all
so much bronze and I can't wait to keep
playing this game and as always
[Music]
I'm gonna you just break on the line